Some people love Apple a lot...
...in the US or UK, even in China, the tech firm's fastest growing market.
And it's not just people who love Apple, shops do too.
And this shop loves Apple so much, it really, really wants to be an Apple store.
Inside, it looks like one of those manicured mansions of must-have gadgetry.
Looks though are deceiving.
Even though the items for sale seem to be the real deal,...
...this shop and another just a few streets away are more than a little iffy.
A keen - eyed American living here in Kunming realized Apple have no official stores in the city;...
...news it seems, to employees.
We only sell real Apple products.
If you ask me if this store is authorized by Apple, I don't know.
You'd need to ask the boss.
Gadgets are big business.
And counterfeit Apple goods are a big problem for the firm...
...and the intellectual property police in China.
Counterfeit shops though, seems to be a new challenge.
A challenge that could be fueled by disloyal or just confused shoppers.
As long as their products are real, it's okay.
After all when you enter the store, you're looking at their products and not anything else.
I wouldn't shop there.
It's a violation of property rights...
...and probably just cosmetically similar.
How can you be so sure of a quality product or service?
Apple have not made an official statement about the unofficial shops.
It is a safe bet though they'll be looking to root out potentially rotten cores.